Biden's going to have a fairly
conventional view of America's
predominance in the world.
China's been able to
gain a lot of ground
internationally by playing
off the US against Europe.
One of the most
important differences
between Biden and Trump is
Biden does believe in diplomacy.
China has shown
itself to be highly
pragmatic in terms of its
foreign relations with the US.
The US election was a month ago.
The legal challenges are
all over, bar the tweeting,
so a presidential transition
is now fully underway.
For president-elect
Biden, how he manages
the relationship with
China is likely to shape
his presidency and a big
part of how the world works.
Ed, you've written a
lot about the impact
the Trump presidency has had on
the US's standing in the world,
and that his reframing of the
west's attitude towards China
is regarded, in the US, as one
of his biggest achievements.
So what would you say
are the key topics that
are going to define the US-China
relationship in the next four
years?
So the most surprising
thing, I think,
is just the element
of continuity here.
As you say, Trump
has kind of branded
a new bipartisan
attitude towards China,
which sees it not as a
potential partner any longer,
but which sees it as a
threat, a strategic rival,
and that includes Democrats.
There was, in my
view, less Sinophobia
in the presidential election
than you might have expected,
but there was still quite
a lot, and it pushed Biden
quite sharply to
the right in terms
of where he used to be
as vice-president, a much
more hawkish voice on China.
So I would expect the Biden
administration to pick up
from Trump in terms of
the hawkishness on trade
and on the deficit and
on intellectual property.
I would expect there to be
considerable attempt to shore
up America's military
presence in the region,
to continue that arms race,
if you like, with China,
but also - and here's the
real departure from Trump -
to approach China with
allies, with partners,
not through an
'America First' prism,
but through multilateral means.
One of the most
important differences
between Biden and Trump is
Biden does believe in diplomacy.
He does believe in
working with allies.
He does believe in what I
call the "constant gardening"
of talking to people and
working in concert with them.
And he believes in the
multilateral system,
and, this means a
couple of things.
First, that he's
going to try and work
with Europe, and
with America's allies
and partners in the
Asia-Pacific region
to develop a common approach
to China on a range of issues.
But he's also going to, perhaps
a bit more controversially,
and really in stark contrast
to Trump, and even to Obama,
is to set up a conference
of democracies.
In other words, a kind
of ideological sort
of rivalry to China's
authoritarian model,
a conscious sort of
ideological opposition
there that has been lacking
in US foreign policy, at least
since the Iraq war.
Now, this common
approach, whether it's
a la carte minilateralism with
allies who want to join in,
or more conventional
multilateralism,
presumably, James,
is not something
that Xi Jinping and the China
leadership wants to see.
It's really China's
worst nightmare.
For the last 40 years of China's
phase of reform and opening
up to the outside
world, China's been
able to gain a lot of ground
internationally by playing off
the US against Europe
and really winning
some concessions in the process.
If the vision of the future
is the US and Europe working
together to constrain
China in some way,
that really closes
off a lot of doors
to the Chinese leadership.
But I think there is
a valid question as to
whether or not the US and the
EU can actually pull this off.
There's an awful
lot of co-ordination
that would be required
to actually achieve
this type of constraining
attitude towards China,
and I think if we
look at the cards
that China has in
its hand, you quickly
see how difficult it could be.
Obviously the main one
is commerce and trade.
China's the biggest trading
country in the world,
has a huge surplus with the US,
has a big surplus with the EU.
There are all kinds
of trade levers
and other commercial
levers that the Chinese
can pull to frustrate and
prevent the US and the EU
working together against China.
Biden will have the same
sort of overall view
that the commercial
relationship with China
is of transcending
importance that Trump has,
but it will be a very different,
very different approach
to how he handles it.
Trump saw it as in very
much 20th-century terms,
as where the bilateral trade
deficit was distributed
on aluminium or steel or
whatever it might have been,
or soybeans.
Biden won't be
obsessed with that.
His team are looking more at
the strategic investment-driven
high-tech stuff,
particularly in AI and 5G,
and the strategic
advantages, as well
as the commercial
advantages, that China is
gaining on the United States.
And I don't think they see the
Trump administration as having
really addressed any of that.
So they will share
one thing, which
is China is a grand
commercial strategic threat,
but at that point, tactically,
they - Biden and Trump are
in different universes.
From a Chinese perspective,
they look at the trade war
that Trump launched
in 2018, and I
think they feel that it
hasn't gone that badly.
For instance, in
the last few months,
the Chinese trade
surplus with the US
has been rising
very sharply indeed.
I think a lot of observers in
this part of the world, when
they think about
the trade war, they
think that China may have won.
But the points that you
mention, the sanctions
by the US government on
key Chinese technologies,
particularly in areas such as
artificial intelligence and 5G
telecoms, and sanctions directed
at particular Chinese companies
such as Huawei, I
think in those areas
China remains very exposed,
and those sanctions
have been very painful for
particular Chinese companies.
So while the
leadership in Beijing
would be wanting those
to be eased or lifted,
I think they're
realistic in knowing
that progress on that
front is pretty unlikely.
But beyond trade and this type
of commercial relationship, Ed,
let me ask you, how do you
see a President Biden dealing
with the geostrategic rivalry
that's come to characterise
the US-China relationship?
The interesting thing,
James, is that Biden's
going to have a fairly
conventional view of America's
predominance in the
world and the need
to maintain its hegemony
in the Asia-Pacific.
So there'll still be
patrols of US naval
- freedom of navigation
patrols in the South China Sea.
There will still be a strong
treaty alliance with Japan.
There will still be
military exercises, probably
more emphasised with
the quad of the US,
Japan, Australia, and India.
It'll be referred
to as Indo-Pacific.
So that conventional role
that America has always had,
and which Obama stepped up
with a pivot to Asia, Biden
will pick up on,
update, and strengthen.
There's not going to be
any radical departure
there from the standard
American administration.
Very radical departure,
though, from Trump
because there will be strong
emphasis on Hong Kong's
freedoms, or diminishing
freedoms on the Xinjiang
situation.
They'll probably meet the
Dalai Lama at some point,
so that that's something
that China will not like,
and with which it
will be very familiar.
On the other hand, Biden
wants to work with China.
He wants to reach out and
develop common positions
on issues like climate change.
Without China, very little
can be accomplished.
With China, you can get
dramatic global progress,
and the appointment of John
Kerry as Biden's climate envoy
is a signal that Biden doesn't
just want rivalry with China,
he also wants friendship.
You could call it a sort
of 'frenemy' situation.
So my question to you,
James, is, can China
do this sort of
walking and chewing
gum of being a rival and a
co-operator at the same time?
Would it... will that work?
Yes, I think walking and
chewing gum for China
is situation normal in
international relations.
I mean, I think for
probably a decade or more
before the Trump
presidency began,
China became used to balancing
rivalry on the one hand
and co-operation with
the US on the other.
So I really don't think
that this will be a stretch.
Of course, when
the US criticises
China on human rights
that will annoy Beijing
and there will be some
kind of a backlash.
Of course there'll
be other irritations,
many other irritations
in the relationship,
but China has shown
itself to be highly
pragmatic in terms of its
foreign relations with the US.
However, this time
around I think
there is one area
that is significantly
different from pre-the
Trump presidency,
and that is the situation and
the tensions around Taiwan.
Taiwan is regarded by China
as an inalienable part
of its territory,
but more and more is
showing self-determination under
the encouragement of the US.
If tensions over Taiwan start
to really spiral then we
are genuinely in new territory,
and very scary territory,
I think, for the whole region
and for the rest of the world.